I think there's a of course a chance
that there are aliens out there in space
I mean no one knows the answer to that
and no one has any particular expertise
so anyone who answers a question on
alien life they're just talking from
their hunch from their gut so here's my
hunch my gut well like most people I
look out on a dark night and I see all
of the stars out there and then I know
about all the galaxies out there you
know hundreds of billions of stars per
galaxy hundreds of billions of galaxies
now we know that many of those stars
have planetary systems and it can't help
but just have a a sense of with all of
that out there there's got to be other
life that somehow is populating some of
those planets but the big question to me
is not so much whether there's other
life out there is there intelligent life
out there now look some will say that we
don't have a single example of
intelligent life in the universe right
but putting that to the side what I mean
is and what many scientists mean is is
there life out there that can build
radio telescopes that could possibly
communicate with us because if there's
life out there and we can't ever
communicate it's hard to see how that's
going to have much of an impact on us on
life as we know it I mean that big the
radical break from the past will be when
we can actually communicate with life
out there and I don't think we know
enough about what it takes for alien
life to become intelligent in this sense
of building radio telescopes to have any
sense if it's likely or unlikely you
know is it some strange coincidence of
having you know big planets nearby like
Jupiter that help deflect asteroids that
allow enough time for life on this
planet to have gotten to the point
are there other contingencies that we
don't know about that are so rare that
may be intelligent life happens only
here we don't know but shooting from the
hip speaking from the gut yeah
there's probably alien life out there
and probably intelligent life too